car is rammed into two capital police
officers
at a barricade outside the u.s capitol
and we're just hearing in the last few
seconds
nbc news are citing law enforcement
sources telling us that the suspect the
driver involved in this incident was a
man
and has died after being shot by capitol
police greg i think you're so on the
phone to us there that's breaking news
the suspect the driver involved was a
man and has died after being shot
by capitol police uh and greg what
what might that mean in terms of the
investigation now
and what the authorities can glean about
motivations
yeah it obviously complicates their
investigation to a degree doesn't it
because they don't have a suspect that
they can talk to
about about their motivations um
it it isn't surprising because police
officers in the u.s capitol police and
every other police officer in the u.s
has the has the lawful right to to um to
use deadly force if it is to protect
their own life or the lives of others so
it's not surprising that they would have
in shooting someone who they they felt
was attacking them that um they would
have used that deadly force
but they will now as we see there is a
clearly
clearly a response there from some of
the top brass of the
law enforcement community around
washington they will be beginning that
job of establishing who this person was
as we see with any investigation of an
incident like this and picking through
that person's life those who know them
and of course
primarily and i don't know if they've
said anything about this yet
yet whether this is part of anything
bigger whether there is someone else
involved
whether there is anyone else they're
looking for very early on they'll want
to establish that
the threat is over that there isn't a
risk to
anyone on the capital anyone who's there
or anyone anywhere else
that will be a a primary aim of the
investigators to ensure there isn't
some sort of conspiracy going on here
and other people that they need to be
looking for
but then they will begin that
investigation and it will be a long
investigation
to to establish who this person is uh
why they did what they did and and the
background to all of that and that work
will have begun
um already you see the the the crime
scene tape is is up
uh the the work will have already
started uh on that vehicle
uh and and who who the person is
responsible for
for what happened on the capital today